earlier this week a 74 year old woman
had to be rescued by helicopter after
she injured herself while hiking and
before I talk about what happened next I
need to tell you the hikers doing fine
she's she's perfectly fine she was not
seriously hurt so that's the good news
but during the rescue and this is what
everyone's talking about this is real
the helicopter hit some turbulence and
this is what happened
yeah that's real and that went on for I
think three minutes three minutes of her
spinning faster and faster and faster
now as I said she is fine this woman is
so courageous for enduring that and I
really wanted to meet her so luckily for
us she said that she would appear on our
show tonight
so we had a big comfortable limousine
pick her up at home and take her
directly to the airport here she comes
now
[Applause]
then we flew her in a private plane from
Arizona and they hit a little turbulence
I'm afraid so that was unfortunate and
but she's been through a lot she's doing
great and she is here with us now please
welcome the rescued hiker everybody
[Applause]
that was really stupid thank you